and my daughter calls me and we had this
conversation and i asked her i said i
said lily i think i might want to give
this a shot
and she said
oh wow okay
kelly if you were given a choice between
working as an executive
for a hundred thousand a year
or working as a screenwriter for twenty
five thousand a year which would you
choose
uh well first of all
um
executives make a lot more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year so
uh i actually had to
make that decision
the top of 2020
when i was offered a promotion
at uh at hbo and i was gonna make a
hundred thousand dollars more than i
made currently and i turned it down
because i also you know they made me an
offer to
take a first look writing deal and i i
jumped at it and it was probably half of
what i was making
so i've actually had this question in
real time in real life
and there's nothing like it i would
never
i think if i if i went back and had to
do it all over again i would make the
same choice there's just nothing like
waking up every day in pure joy and
knowing that
the the first thing that i get to do is
crack open my computer and the last
thing i'm doing all day is you know
still being you know
wired into that computer just
downloading everything that's in my head
so there's just getting paid to write
there's just no question
do you think you would have really taken
that let's say
i know you had some
jobs out of college where you were you
know as sort of an admin assistant or
helping agents things like that but the
the lure of of six figures or more
um
do you think that it takes time to
realize
what is important
well let me see if i if i understand
your question um if you're saying
that it did it take me 30 years to know
that i wanted to be a writer i don't i
don't know that i
i don't think i was consciously aware
in all of that time that i was an
executive that i was planning on making
a transition i think
i had started out as a writer's
assistant when i was
you know just coming out of college it
was one of my i think it was my third
job that i'd ever had in the
entertainment business
and i knew that i wanted to do that i
wanted to be a part of the creative
process and i tried
casting and i knew that that wasn't
really it even though i loved the
process i love the people i was working
with
and i think i was looking for my place
and i it felt right because i'd always
been writing i'd been writing you know
since i was a kid
you know creating short plays and short
stories and you know doing all those
things actually creating a magazine so
for my family so i knew that i wanted to
somehow
channel all that into writing
but when i was coming out of college the
world was very different than it is now
there just weren't a lot of places for
an african-american
young woman
who wanted to write
in in the ecosystem and when i looked
around i didn't see a lot of people who
looked like me either in
either in executive ranks or
as a as a writer on staff of a show so i
felt as though
there were not a whole lot of doors that
were open for me there were not a lot of
places that i could go
so
i think if if the world had been
different if i had come out now as a
writer if i was doing that you know when
i was 20 something years old and doing
it now boy sky's the limit but at the
time
i made the best choice that i could with
the information that i could and with
the
knowledge that i needed to make a living
and that there were not going to be a
lot of opportunities for me
so
um
so i do feel as though
going into as an executive route was the
perfect place for me because i could
still work with the creative i could
still
be a part of that
writing process only from the
hey let me help you
you know let's talk about your project
let's figure out where you want to go
and how to get there and and the
packaging part that you do as you're in
a network executive or as a feature
executive so i do feel as though it
really satisfied a lot of those
cravings of working with material and i
think i was really good at it
and i got a chance to see the industry
from a very very different perspective
than a lot of writers do so i saw the in
inner workings and realized oh there are
so many different decisions that get in
you know that are part of the
of the creative process that are on the
business side
that you don't see as a writer you only
know the work that you've put out but
you don't know all the other things that
make into the decision-making process of
why this thing moves forward versus
something else that doesn't move forward
and then once it does move forward well
what else do you have to do in order to
support that piece of material you know
from the marketing and and advertising
and all of the other
aspects of it so i think i got a really
great insider view into the business on
both the feature side and the tv side
that i probably wouldn't have had so i
kind of feel like i got baked in a
different way i was always writing
though and i think that that that
that need for me to express myself
on the page was always there so
i don't think you have to go through 30
years of you know how i did it that was
just
a kind of a
a weird way to you know for me to do it
but i know that there are there's also a
very long legacy of of executives who
turned writers i don't know that they
talk about it
but um but it's not like i blazed a
whole new path
um
and i i do feel like you know i sort of
got to the right place at the right time
okay so maybe not the 30-year journey
maybe if you were to give advice to
someone on
a paycheck versus feeling creatively
fulfilled
well i think that's always the balance
isn't it you know i was actually just uh
talking to a group of people recently
about that you know art versus commerce
and how much
you know can you survive on
while you were fulfilling your dream and
how and what does success look like to
you so
you know there might be writers who are
are completely content having you know
doing plays in in um
regional theater you know and that's a
success as a writer so i think whatever
you feel as though
your calling is in this it doesn't have
to be that you're winning an oscar
doesn't have to be that you're making a
marvel feature
you know you can write and be satisfied
by that writing and create
in so many different ways
and yeah the money thing is is it's hard
it's harder when you get
older it's certainly harder if i did
this when i was 24 years old and right
out of college
and my i think my rent at the time this
was back at 80 something
my rent at the time was 450 a month
that was it that's all i had to make
to cover that nut
now it's like i got a mortgage i've got
three kids there was college education
you know there's a lot more that you
know there's there's car insurance
there's homeowners and shares there's so
many things that just become
so much more oppressive and you have to
make different choices
based on what's coming in and what's not
coming in
i have the luxury now of having an
expertise in something that people want
that thing can support me as i also
pursue this writing so if it's not if
it's a lean month you know i'll have
something to fall back on that's the
benefit you know and i think also my age
you know at at my age now
there be there's a as
i don't know if it's it's like a
feeling of being settled and knowing
that you have worth and you have value
that i don't think i had when i was in
my 20s in my 20s i thought oh it's going
to be my last job ever it was always the
thing oh my god they're never going to
hire me i'm never going to work again
you don't have that when you're in your
50s
because you know you've got something
that you're bringing to the table
what about
peer pressure family pressure to make
money or maybe it's not even spoken it's
just oh hey it's a family get together
and so and so they just now their
partner at a new firm and what are you
up to you know that kind of thing where
you know you feel like you have to
explain yourself i think uh
i i have the benefit of coming from a
family that's incredibly supportive
and my mother who is my biggest
cheerleader
and uh and every single morning you know
calls me up and says you know calls me
her precious child and just thinks that
i'm a genius so i think that that's that
helps
um
and when i made this decision to to jump
off the edge of the cliff
i happen i know exactly when it was i
could probably even pinpoint the day and
the moment
because it was very very important to me
i happened to be at sundance i was in
the episodic lab this is 2019.
it was in october
it was
the day before we were going to finish
the program and
uh
and it probably was a saturday actually
if i'm really being specific um and i
was in line to get my
uh to get dinner it was a buffet line
and my daughter calls me and we had this
conversation and i asked her i said i
said lily i think i might want to give
this a shot
and she said
oh wow okay she said if not now mom when
and for me i was like
i birthed the right child because
i said look it we might actually end up
having to have you know make some
choices financially because look i was
coming off of a really nice
svp job at a major
studio
you know network
and uh
and she just said uh hey we'll be okay
we'll figure it out
and at this point i think my
my kids were
i think i was probably i don't know i'm
trying to think if i just graduated from
my mfa program or i think i had just
graduated from my mfa program and they
my kids were still in school so they
were still
you know it was their last year of
college and i think her last year of
maybe of her
graduate school
and
and again i feel like there was just
this
understanding that we could all figure
it out together and that it wasn't that
important that the trappings of
life
the cars the house the whatever the
vacations that we would go on were just
not that important compared to
mom finding herself
and i
i just couldn't have asked for a better
um support system so i do feel as though
when you're
when you're somebody who doesn't have
that when you have to really struggle
and you have to do that for yourself
you do need to find people who are going
to
um
acknowledge your dream and support your
dream
and to encourage your dream because i
think that a lot of writers
i think that's probably the biggest
thing that's the that's one of the
biggest hurdles i think imposter
syndrome and the the fact that no one's
in your corner saying hey keep going
that's what makes us give up right
that's what makes us feel like
you know maybe we're
you know
charging in the wrong direction or we're
we're not on the right path because
there are all these pressures they're
all these people who
who um
you know until you until you've made
something until you've
until you've gotten that acknowledgement
you don't know
if you're doing the right thing you just
don't know
and i've i think i've seen a lot of
interviews with a lot of people who have
made it
and they still don't know they still
worry they still don't know if what they
have
created is anything that's worthy of
being
seen or shown or read
so i do feel as though there's a
there's you got to close that gap
someplace and luckily i had
i had a whole team of people
who were willing to help me close that
gap does lily want to be a writer
creative you know i keep asking lily if
she would if she would do it she's a
beautiful writer she had to write she
she went to college and got a
a degree in american studies and film
and the the pieces that she wrote were
just wonderful it drives her bananas she
doesn't love the process but i think
that's also maybe a factor of age as
well because at that age for me writing
was a chore and
and i did not enjoy it now i enjoy it
now i enjoy the
cracking it open trying to figure out
the pieces of the puzzle that make it
work so it might be that she will get
there eventually which which she is
amazing at and by the way she's my
assistant now and i'm i'd be lost
without her but what she's amazing at is
finding material so she will because
she's an avid reader and i'm i believe
her she and her sister sarah last year
read between 35 and 38 books
just and that's just them that's they
just turn and consume material
and she found me a project that ended up
getting an offer from a studio so she's
really good and i really trust her
instincts so i would love it if she
would right
i'm not sure that she will
but
i'm also seeing if she i would push her
to if she wanted to be a development
executive she'd be great at it